i asked gary veeda as that question the  difference between delusion  and perseverance  and when gary v says you have to see  something meaning you need to see  progression right there needs to be some  part of improvement so if you're doing  content  from year one you're getting 10 views  you're five you're getting 11.  to me it's just like  that's progression but bro  yeah you didn't really you had progress  you didn't have progress you should be  seeing consistent growth yeah and you  should be you should look back to your  old content and kind of cringe  because you've grown and elevated so  much 100 i have people i went to high  school with that i've been hearing since  high school dude i'm i'm rapping i'm  making music i'm gonna be the next big  thing yeah still  oh wait for me dude it's been [ __ ]  like 10 years dude yeah maybe it's not  for you um  [Music]  you